well Acacio Cortez doesn't seem very
worried about jobs that will be lost due
to automation because far more jobs will
be lost implementing the green New Deal
Patrick Moore helped found Greenpeace he
has been aggressively critical of the
green new deal though and we thought
we'd find out why mr. thanks very much
for coming on so you're one of the
founders of the most famous
environmental organization in the world
and you think the green New Deal sounds
terrifying
tell us why well because it would be
basically the end of a civilization if
85% of the world's and also 85% of the
US is energy in the form of coal oil and
natural gas were phased out over the
next few years like 10 years we do not
have anything to replace them with yes
if we went into a crash course of
building nuclear reactors we could
replace them for producing electricity
but that isn't going to happen because
the greens are against nuclear and
they're even against hydroelectric dams
which at least is renewable but they
don't support that either so basically
they are opposed to approximately 98.5
percent of all the electricity that we
are using and of nearly a hundred
percent of all the vehicle and
transportation and ships and planes
energy that we are using so I just want
when I tweeted the other day and had a
huge response over three million
impressions on Twitter when I said you
don't have a plan to feed 8 billion
people without fossil fuels or get the
food into the cities where it's needed
that requires large trucks and there's
not going to be any electric trucks any
time soon hauling 40 tons of food into
the supermarkets where the people in the
cities probably think it originates in
the supermarket but it does not it's
coming from farms out in the country
where a few million people are growing
the food for all the rest of the
population and if we ban fossil fuels
first agricultural production would
collapse in a very short period of time
there's these things called tractors and
they use fuel and all the other
implements on the farm and then there's
the transportation so when when you have
no
fuel how do you get the food to the
center of New York to Manhattan where
AOC is from you don't then the people
there will begin to starve and that will
spread out as a rot from the center of
the metropolis --is all across the
country and half the population will die
in a very short period of time
and as I also pointed out there wouldn't
be a tree left on this planet say this
was a worldwide thing because the United
States isn't going to ban fossil fuels
if no one else does but say the Paris
agreement came into effect fully all
around the world and everybody banned
fossil fuels there wouldn't be a tree
left on this planet because that would
be all there was for fuel for heating
and cooking as they did in the old days
when there was hardly anybody on the
planet compared to what there is today
so just that one point
never mind the insanity of banning
aircraft and fossil fuel using vehicles
well you've just completely blown my
mind and and I knew some of that but the
way you put it was really stirring Pecha
more I hope you'll come back on the show
anytime anytime Tucker thank you